we're working through vehicle body
construction right now so you're seeing
like various buddy sub assemblies get
created and then we'll we'll reach the
end of the buddy production line you'll
see a completed car buddy
- smart fascinating to see this together
the car getting constructed you know
spent like westlaw for cars cars yeah
Westborough we look around these things
about that like intersection
in terms of the dimensional precision
and we're not there yet but I think
we're getting there very quickly I want
them all three to be so accurate like
you could you couldn't use it as a
yardstick that's like at equator turn
but I mean it's like like if you have a
tape measure or something and the tape
measure gives a different number than
the size of the car your tape measure is
wrong oh this is dimensional engineering
lab this is kind of cool so we were I
was like saying like the golf or the
model three is to have ten times the
precision of any other craft so we're
putting a trace not infinity to ensuring
that the the gaps and flush this and the
dimensions of the car are incredibly
precise and we just keep at it and at it
and at it and until you really can't
even tell where the precise instrument
that there's any different flowing part
of the next big flat thing is that the
battery yes that's the battery and then
the part that sort of work called pin
house weren't getting yes that's a bunch
of control electronics for the battery
as well as where the charger the car
charger resides and it wasn't this part
of the problem getting the production of
the battery factory but didn't that add
to the delay of the model 3 though for
you yes getting that battery technically
the modules in the battery for the and
so are the lagging elements of
production very rapidly catching up
there's a part of me that thinks yeah
you must feel confident otherwise you
wouldn't allow cameras here you can
listen Willie like
give us zero seconds of notice at any
point and bring your camera crew into
any part of the factory at any time
like literally like you should do this
and just come with a carry yes
Elan be careful what you say I'm not
kidding
how definitely do that